When the first trailer for the ninth Fast
and Furious film dropped at the Fast 9 Festival
in Miami on January 31, fans of the nearly
two-decade-long action franchise were gifted
a shocking surprise.
After winning over audiences in 2006's The
Fast and The Furious: Tokyo Drift, Han Lue,
the effortlessly cool street racer, thief,
businessman, and former member of Dominic
Toretto's crew, is back from the dead.
Played by Sung Kang, he died in the third
Fast and Furious movie, the first in the franchise
directed by Justin Lin.
Though he appeared in the next three films,
the saga's timeline puts his death after the
events of Fast & Furious 6.
Thus, fans have believed for more than a decade
that Han's fate in the universe had been sealed.
"Time for you to do your own thing."
"Heard they're doing some crazy s--- in Tokyo."
Yet, there he is in the trailer, characteristically
snacking as he enters a room full of his former
crew mates.
This, of course, begs the question: How is
Han still alive after audiences saw him die?
We Got This Covered claims to know the answer.
Take the following with a grain of salt, but
the outlet alleges that Han simply escaped
his car before it became enveloped in flames.
Unidentified and unverified sources close
to the outlet say that Han has been in hiding,
staying under the radar of those he knows
would be after him following the fateful incident.
The site also reported that the character
will make an appearance in the saga's 10th
and final film, slated for an April 2021 release.
However Han Lue makes his long-desired return
in F9, the news of his survival has been a
shot of adrenaline to the fanbase of the Fast
franchise.
After being with each other for more than
a decade, the cast has evolved into a family
as much as the characters have.
Han was a huge part of that, which helped
convince director Justin Lin to bring the
character back into Dom's family and back
into the Fast universe.
As Lin told Entertainment Weekly:
"I think it's really up to us to bring him
back and explore it throughout the themes
that we're all used to."
The fans certainly seem happy.
On Twitter, the announcement that Han would
return got the hashtag #HanIsAlive trending.
It also appeared to renew the trust of Fast
diehards who felt betrayed by the movies after
it gave Han's killer Deckard Shaw prime billing
in two films following the popular character's
death.
As it happens, Lin has a long history with
Han, since the character was first introduced
in Lin's 2002 crime drama feature debut Better
Luck Tomorrow.
Actor Sung Kang revealed in a 2013 interview
with Mandatory that Han was added to the Fast
and Furious franchise only after Lin convinced
executives to change up another proposed character.
Clearly, Han is not only beloved by the Fast
fandom, but he's also a character Lin has
carried with him through his career.
Han is a prime example of the narrative the
Fast and Furious saga has built around found
family, and that may be important going into
the next film.
Lin is certainly not treating the character's
return lightly.
He told Entertainment Weekly:
"In this world, I feel like things happen
for a reason.
I won't go into details or anything, but I
do think that bringing him back is nothing
I take lightly - and it took a lot - but I
think what I appreciate is that this universe
has really grown and it allows us to evolve
and really kind of redefine ourselves as we
go."
As Han himself would say:
"Life's simple.
You make choices, and you don't look back."
As for Sung Kang, the experience of returning
to the screen as the fan-favorite is as big
for him as it is for the fans who have desperately
wanted to see him back.
He told the Los Angeles Times:
"It's emotional - it feels like I'm going
back to a family reunion.
It's a relationship that has been missing
in my life since the last Fast."
See Han Lue make his long-awaited return when
F9 drives into theaters on May 22.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.